all right kathy
yes cathy where'd you grow up where you
from originally i was born in
los angeles south central
raised in a single parent home even
though i have seven
other siblings how was your childhood
it was very dysfunctional government
cheese
free peanut butter county um
check food stamps um
pretty much no attention from anyone um
in our park in the in a one-bedroom
apartment
locked in a room all by myself
mom and dad my dad is doing life
never met him and my mother had me at 40
and my dad was like 20
and um she pretty much
didn't pay any attention to me i raced
myself
um bill cosby and sesame street pretty
much were my parents any
traumatic events in your childhood or
yes by the age of eight years old
um my stepfather after my mother would
have like
five guys over and herself
playing cards drinking um she'll pass
out and um
although the three guys were leaving my
step that i was staying
eventually started coming into my
bedroom and um
i was given a moral sex pretty much from
the age of eight to twelve
he was finger playing me and then all of
a sudden by the time i was getting ready
to turn um
13 he wanted to take my virginity
so i took my backpack and i left home
now by this time my mother had already
knew
at the age of nine she put a gun to my
head and she said oh girl what goes on
and this house stays in his house do you
understand so i was very quiet
shy i went to school every day and i'll
sit in the front and i'll be the
teacher's pet because
that's pretty much the only place i got
attention
was for my school teachers and maybe
some of my other classmates
and when i i am i never wore um
skirts if i did dresses to church
only on sundays and i always wear um
shorts under my dress
i was real shy real
smart i'm pretty i'm so smart um
i make so many dumb mistakes because i
don't believe in myself and i
my self-worth is like still really low
how did it make you feel that your mom
didn't believe you or support you
or protect you pretty much um
we i found out like her
uncle molested her when she was child
and she was born in 1936
and she's caucasian and african american
um and her dad my german grandfather
he already had a wife and um he disowned
her in
black and white days um she pretty much
was raised by her uncle
and she was neglected so i come from
a dysfunctional neglected mother who
raised her children also
in a dysfunctional neglected situation
and um alcohol was her thing she loved
alcohol popping pills
and she was a sex thing oh my god
i learned about orgies and drugs and
man all kind of
like pills and
from beards a hard liquor and she even
let me drink
alcohol in my bottle at two and also
um by the time i was like eight nine ten
um
i was popping my i wasn't popping open
my own cans of beer
and you could go to the store with a
letter
once the store called and um get it
approved where you could
buy beer for your parents to take it
back home so now i'm going to school in
sixth grade and i'm buying my own beers
in my home six pack and
sharing them in elementary school by the
time i was in junior high
i had dts i had to have a beer every day
before i go to class and pretty much
before i went to bed
i still drink to this day you know um
leaving home at 13 i
got hooked up with this gang called a
trey hoover's
off of manchester and hoover and i
really fell in love
um a lot of guys um
showed me a lot of attention um embraced
me
and treated me like i was a little
sister a family i never had and um
so i went from stealing even though i
stayed in um
school still making great good grades
um but ditching and partying from
drinking to weed smoking
i'm not pcp
um i'm pregnant at 16 in the 12th grade
graduating from high school accepted
into a four-year university at cal state
to meet hills
and i have been working at
jack-in-the-box from 14
and i had my own apartment by the time i
was
18 and there and working two jobs
going to going to college and i
have the same problem dysfunctional baby
daddies and
so now i'm a single parent and
age of 23 from snorting cocaine
already and popping ecstasy pills and
pretty much curiosity the cat thank god
i'm still here i mean
i might probably be living on my eighth
or ninth life by now
but um so what is your drug today today
i still drink
um like some marijuana
um crack and i started smoking crack at
age 23
43 so 20 year history um
i was a real crackhead when i started
off the first 10 years
and then i became a rock star but the
drugs are so terrible today
you don't even get no cocaine in the
crack so all of us whack
so i i drink every now and then um
i went to prison went in and out of jail
from eight to three
35 years old hit um chancellor
three years and wow that was not
so cool it's very scary frightening
i met some lifers and told me you got
another chance to make it
so these last seven years i've been out
of um prison
still downtown um honestly i had um
had an apartment and had a man and
but he's controlling and he's a muslim
man he wanted me to do everything
his way he beat me and i thought it was
love because he showed me attention
though you know
and that's what i never had right that's
all i wanted was somebody to really love
me
and then i found out he was sleeping
with my 25 year old daughter oh yeah
so i had the child of a girl september
11 she'll be
26 this year and then 11 months
later i had a son they're not even a
year apart two different baby daddies
yeah
because the first one was no good and so
i have
a two that's like in
almost the same age like a year like
next week my son will be 25 and my
daughter's still 25 but they're not
twins right
and um and then i have a 22 year old
well because crap became my life my
friend my buddy
after the separation of my second
children's father because i realized he
put his mother before
everything and i couldn't stand it
because i hated my mother so how could
you love your mother more than me
and so i walked out left him as young as
two kids
my oldest went to my sister in
1999 woo party like a rock star downtown
l.a skid row
and i'm the prettiest thing downtown so
they say
huh man i get hooked up with
biggest dope dealers down here i don't
even have to do too much but pretty
much be pretty in smoke
well the party never ended and um
it's like a nightmare like how can this
girl
me straight a student is so smart
i even speak lying languages you know um
and it's like
oh my wanted to be a school teacher
dreams go i want to love to help
others maybe be the first woman
president who knows right
well i don't know
things happens when then you begin you
get by you become
bipolar and then i find out i got mental
issues and
who ptsd and adhd you see i can't really
stop moving i can't be still too much
and um i take my meds but go to
counseling
hmm i'm just lost and i'm still downtown
l.a
the city of hope well i hope one day
um you know i can find
the true me i don't know um
drugs cigarettes that's why i've been
smoking cigarettes since i was 18
still smoking cigarettes got a nasty
ugly call people
i'm like it's not corona you know
please if i don't have corona thank god
but um what was it what was the lowest
point of your life
the lowest point of my life is pretty
much i went to prison
left home at 14 and never went back home
to mom
my mother passed away adam
as much as i hated her she was my best
friend
because any time i needed so she would
still be there
you know right now after seven years of
getting out of prison and living with
this man
all my stuff is in storage because i had
a private video after i
realized that me and my daughters
together
i went into a program and
got clean and stayed off everything for
about six months
and social security
my income got cut off last year and i'm
back here
i'm homeless again without a key
i've been downtown back you know like i
said i've been down here
about 20 years it has been 20 years
i'll be 44 in two months
and i don't know sometimes i wish
i had it i don't have any stds
i still could think i'm computer
illiterate
of computer phobia everything's on
computer
um i don't know what to do
i wanted to be an actress but
illuminati sacrificing people and
i don't know i don't wear makeup
where do you live now now now i stay
wherever i
just people's tent where i fall asleep
um i've been down here so other people
have sros they
invite me over to their homes what are
you doing for money
for many i recycle and
i lost all my wallet everything and it's
just like i gotta start all over
everything's closed it's like right now
i'm at the
bottom of my bottom and i don't know how
to get out
i really don't know how to get out
and to be a domestic violence um
victim
you would think i should be able to get
some help but i'm lying to you busy
oh come back gotta have id um
it's just like i don't know where to
start it's like i'm just
walking i'm not exit i'm just existing
i'm not living life
but i'm afraid i kill myself
i have three children
my 22 year old she's an officer
somewhere in
ontario she know i don't like police but
then
the police saved me and rescued me from
myself
and um my son he's
a criminal like me five years two
strikes in prison
he'd be 25. in a week
my 25 year old the one who's slept with
my ex boyfriend
come to find out she's schizophrenia and
she's hooked on crystal math then
i don't know where she is
so pretty much that's this that's where
i'm at today like
i'll bathe in a bucket get some water
from
water hydrant what's the worst thing
about living on the street like this
i can't stand a rat and these rats
are bigger than i am um
pretty much the rats i've never been
afraid of people because i'm in the
streets
i was 13.
that's the rat and also
the corona virus like
i had shelter i was in a place almost
seven
years from program for four year two
having a single to having a one bedroom
with a key and now i don't even have my
storage key because i lost it
my mother ashes in there and i oh like
right now
eighty-seven dollars on my storage and i
can't even pay that
where do you think you'll be in five ten
years
hopefully not dead if corona don't get
me first
and the positive side
working on maybe going to tarzana
treatment center or
i don't know i don't know
you know seven years i haven't been back
to prison and never been back to jail
my record got expunged i could get my
prison record
trapped and expunged and then three
years i could steal the deal and
i'll be a new person what stops you from
getting a job
i was working at walmart and part-time
i stopped myself pretty much i need id
need a social security card just all the
things that i need to do that i
pretty much it's like
i don't have any uh to even start all
over
how many times have i started over i
don't
i don't know what to do
i don't have any help you would think
out of my mother's
well one of them's deceased my sister
and my brother
so kind of make about four other sisters
i have
maybe five
no four you would think maybe they were
wondering where their little baby sister
is and
how she's doing huh they never cared
what i was born anyway
my street family knows me more than my
my biological family and
i'm still trying to find myself
i wish i could work with like oprah
winfrey
or michelle obama even hillary clinton
i mean honestly to really want to
continue
my life to go into politics and change
the white house to we the people house
paint every color of the rainbow
because i don't see color when i see
people um
i would not want to be the president i
want to go into the judicial
legislation part i want to rewrite
change and create recreate a newer order
for the good of mankind every child bar
should have
food shelter clothing education
immunization
all over the world like
what is wrong with you people who don't
really
love yourself i love myself when i hurt
myself and self-sabotage myself
because pain it eases everything that
i'm going through
but i don't do my best i've
never done my best if i do my best
maybe i'll be a millionaire
thank you thank you thank you so much
you're welcome
you